Baye theorem this formula it's Central
to scientific discovery it's a core tool
in machine learning and Ai and it's even
been used for treasure hunting when in
the 1980s a small team led by Tommy
Thompson and I'm not making up that name
used basan search tactics to help
uncover a ship that had sunk a century
and a half earlier and the ship was
carrying what in today's terms amounts
to $700 Million worth of gold so it's a
formula worth understanding but of
course there were multiple different
levels of possible understanding at the
simplest there's just knowing what each
one of the parts means so that you can
plug in numbers then there's
understanding why it's true but maybe
the most important level is being able
to recognize when you need to use
it